at the front of the queue and certainly
those who have
been given vip access include king
felipe vi of spain seen there with his
wife
leticia
he
has paid his respects in westminster
great hall
we did see just a little earlier ursula
von der lyon also appearing down there
and also uh in the last few minutes the
swedish
uh king
carl gustaf
also paying his respects at westminster
great hall and i expect that we will see
an awful lot of foreign dignitaries and
foreign heads of states and kings and
queens over the rest of the afternoon
many of them have arrived in last 24
hours ahead of the funeral tomorrow and
after they come to westminster hall and
pay their respects many of them are
choosing them to go on to
lancaster house which is a house used by
the foreign commonwealth office where
there is a book of condolence they can
sign there and there hasn't been
or aren't official books of condolence
for the queen's passing
that have been organized by the royal
household this at this death there is a
virtual
uh book that can be signed but they are
keeping a traditional
full book of condolence for
dignitaries and foreign monarchs
who will be able to sign that at
lancaster house
after they've been to westminster hall
if they choose to